it became clear very soon after arriving
yesterday they weren't going to find any
more uh survivors uh in this burnt out
wreckage uh that i'll give you a look at
behind me and certainly that has been
confirmed now by uh authorities that
they are no longer looking for survivors
this is a recovery operation uh 18
people have been confirmed
to have died so far in in this attack
but there are still many many missing
some have been found in hospital there
were 40 people reported missing uh
initially some of those have been found
in hospital but certainly more than half
uh remain missing so uh it is feared
that the
death toll will grow human remains have
been uh recovered uh from the site and
relatives who are looking for their
loved ones that are giving their dna to
a local police station in the hope of uh
getting some news and some answers as to
what happened uh but away from this uh
very grim recovery operation now is also
a war crimes investigation there were
investigator investigators down here
yesterday a large number of them
and certainly as evidence has emerged to
show that there was a missile strike
on this shopping center something russia
denies and in his overnight
address president zielenski actually
released cctv footage himself very
dramatic images to show a missile uh
hitting this shopping center in
kremenchuk this industrial town in the
heart of ukraine uh so certainly uh
prosecutors and investigators will be
pouring over this evidence now uh to try
and uh work out whether this was a
deliberate hit something that president
zielinski says
it was but
aside from whether they managed to prove
if russia intentionally targeted this
shopping center what it doesn't change
is the fact that attacks on civilian
areas like this continue
to happen and ukrainian people continue
to feel
at risk country-wide here these missile
strikes
are across the country not just in the
eastern donbass region or on the capital
kiev as we saw
earlier in the week and one other thing
i should say to uk is that they're also
investigating the fact that during the
air raid siren here shortly before that
attack uh people didn't evacuate the
building and certainly i think after
four months of war people have become a
little bit more relaxed here when it
comes to these air raid sirens which go
off in every city almost every day but
certainly that mood is changing
civilians across the country are feeling
much more threatened